Foundation aiming has asked me to
introduce our dinner speaker for tonight
Nick Gillespie editor of reason calm and
reason TV and she also asked me to
remind you all that this May will be May
2013 will be the 45th anniversary of the
start of Reason magazine reason was
started by a journalism student at
Boston University Lanny Friedlander who
died about a year ago strange kid very
creative but just really disorganized I
learned about Reason magazine in its
third issue and drove to Boston to meet
Lanny and concluded that thinking maybe
I would get involved in helping with
this project because the country really
needed a libertarian magazine
she's the sky is so bizarre and and so
disorganized I just didn't want to get
involved in a project with him but six
months after that I had I had written an
article that he'd persuaded me to ride
he made it the cover story of the
September 6 1969 edition and I was
hooked
somehow that journalism had power and no
a year later a year later
Tibor McCann Manny Costner and I bailed
out Lanny because he was out of money
and was a reason was about to go under
so we we bought it from him in quotes
meaning we took over the liability to
the four hundred subscribers that he had
accumulated and couldn't fulfill and
brought it to California and January 71
was our first issue of this little
partnership called Reason enterprises
and we never missed an issue reason in
1960 in 1970 had only I think published
three issues because of money problems
and disorganisation but we published on
a regular monthly schedule from then on
in 1978 we finally decided that this was
too big of a project we built it to
10,000 circulation too big of a project
to do as a hobby business and it needed
to be something that a few of us could
actually make a living at and so we
created recent foundation we
incorporated it in Santa Barbara and
started with three employees and today
thanks to David knot we have over 60
employees and this wonderful set of
talents that you've all seen now I don't
really need to do much introduction of
Nick and his always bio is in the book
and so forth and I think you all know
him but I want to tell you a little
story that that made a big impression on
me just a couple of weeks ago I was in
New York for the I'm in New York I was
in Washington for the huge annual
Transportation Research Board conference
this brings about 11,500 people like me
policy wonks academics state d-o-t
people federal highway administration
people and the people a lot of them from
all over the world for five intense days
of presentations committee meetings and
so forth on on transportation while I
was there I decided to have lunch with
an old friend dan Elwell who was the
policy chief in the Federal Aviation
Administration when Mary Peters was
secretary during the second term of the
Bush administration dan is a great guy
is a former Air Force pilot worked for
American Airlines for many years and he
became policy chief at FAA he was about
to go to work for the airline trade
association I really wanted to talk dan
was a true believer
in my ideas about air traffic control
what we need to do stuff early well he's
about to go to work for the airlines
group I should really have lunch with
him and bring him up to date and just
talk Turkey so we had a really nice
lunch we spent about 45 or 50 minutes
talking about air traffic control and
they said to me wow I want to ask you
about recent foundation is that the same
thing as this recent TV so I had to
explain it I mean you know the whole the
whole organization the different pieces
and so forth and then he says to me this
guy he still had very short hair very
you know he's about 50 the very sort of
model of establishment Republican you
would assume from looking at me says I
see this guy Nick Gillespie on
television all the time in his leather
jacket and he's so cool he he makes
these free market ideas trendy and hip
and I said where do you faeces where did
you find this guy and so I'm so
delighted that that my my straight-laced
Republican friend thinks Nick Gillespie
is making these ideas so cool and I've
just very pleased now give you our
dinner speaker Nicholas
thank you
it's that's a very flattering story and
I have two things to say before I start
my talk and the first is when I became
editor-in-chief I started with reason in
1993 in the fall and then I became
editor and chief of the magazine in 2000
and the last hurdle was I had to have a
conversation with Bob and his first
question to me is like Nick you know we
think you could be a good editor and
everything but I gotta ask you do you
believe in reality because of various
things had written I was like yeah I
guess I do you know I don't want to be
held to that answer but Bob put faith in
me and signed off on the deal so I was
able to continue at work at reason so
thank you very much for that Bob and it
is I mean you know one of the things
that is you know and to hear about
reasons 45th anniversary to know about
that coming I had started reading reason
when I was in high school my brother my
older brother went to college and
discovered it at his College Bookstore
started sending home to me and then I
later applied for a job I was in grad
school in Buffalo and so I applied for a
job that was listed in the you know they
said they needed an assistant editor and
I'd been a journalist before I went to
grad school and it was the dream job in
all sorts of ways and remains that to
actually be able to participate in a
magazine that had actually really helped
form all of my thoughts and all of my
ideas about the world and so again Bob
thank you for creating this opportunity
for all of us
the other thing I want to say things by
the way are looking up for Harrisburg
since Jim Epstein who's not here tonight
but is a great reason TV producer things
are looking up because he reported today
that a sinkhole developed in Harrisburg
and actually a bunch of buildings fell
into it so and that's unfortunately
about the best news that Harrisburg can
hope for and it's a city really where
the survivors Mb the dead okay so I'm
going to run through five unacknowledged
unexpected and unavoidable facts about
government spending in the economy and
then after I talk for about 15 minutes
and then we'll have some Q&A about all
sorts of whatever's on your mind
okay so the first fact which is
unacknowledged
by many is that we're spending too much
this is a chart of using 2005 dollars
and it's billions of dollars the way
that the government is spending the
actual numbers matter less than the
overall trajectory which you can see is
incredibly high we're spending a lot of
money this is total government spending
it's a different before this is federal
federal spending in 2005 dollars over
the basically the 21st century and you
can see things are up about 50% in
absolute terms this is total government
spending local state and federal
government as a share of GDP the big
spike towards the I guess would be your
left of the chart that's world war two
and you can see us we're coming down a
little bit but when you factor in all
this we're spending a hell of a lot of
money and that when I said it's an
unacknowledged fact that's because we
have dissenters or discontents about
this who include Barack Obama who
recently are told John Boehner that we
don't have a spending problem and of
course Boehner is not a particularly
reliable source unfortunately this is a
guy who I
the part-time in Ohio and John Boehner
is actually my congressman but a couple
of weeks before he became Speaker of the
House in 2011 he was asked by NBC News
to you know could you you say that we're
spending too much money could you name a
program that should be cut and he
actually said on national news you know
it really can't think of anything off
the top of my head
so it's like which but in any case so
some people say we're not spending too
much we don't have a spending problem
Jonathan shade a writer at New York
magazine who Matt and I and various
other reason contributors wrangled with
all the time on online he says there
really isn't money to be cut everywhere
and then there's a kind of tell-all and
Matt has a great editorial in the second
or the next two most recent issue about
people who talk like this but there's a
regular construction that you will see
again and again if you read the Beltway
press which is you know we don't have a
spending problem what we have is a
health care problem or a defense problem
or an aging problem or you know sunspots
that's the problem but it's never
spending so that's an unacknowledged an
unavoidable fact another unacknowledged
and unavoidable and disturbing fact is
that we've got too much debt this is
gross public debt so that includes
public debt held by the public in terms
of bonds and things like that as well as
all of the money that the government
owes to itself so when the government
takes the money out of the Social
Security trust fund and spends it
elsewhere and puts an IOU in there this
is all in that and again this is an
absolute dollar there are constant
dollars I'm sorry this is in percentage
of GDP but you can see where we've gone
from starting at the 21st century which
by the way I don't know any of you who
grew up in the 20th century but the 21st
century was supposed to be pretty cool
and it really is not turning out quite
the way that we envisioned
you know there's no jet packs there's no
dog walks out on the side of your hover
pod or anything like that from the
Jetsons but in 2000 dead as a percentage
of GDP was about 55 percent now it's
over a hundred percent of GDP this is
gross public debt for state and local
governments and you can see something
similar happen there it's smaller but it
started at about fifteen percent of GDP
and it got up to about 20 percent and
it's crested down a little bit because
states basically used a lot of the
stimulus money that they got to pay down
some of their debt it did not as I think
most of us understand did not stimulate
the economy quite the way as it was
intended and yet here you have more
discontents talking about this Larry
Summers who some of you is anybody from
Harvard here okay I'll speak slower but
Larry Summers you know governments that
enjoy such low borrowing cost can
improve their creditworthiness by
borrowing more not less and you wonder
like how did we get in to this situation
oh yeah you know it's it's just
dumbfounding isn't it david dayan a
blogger at Firedoglake which is a
left-wing site we have a broad capacity
to borrow loads of money at ultra low
rates government should capitalize on it
and then Paul Krugman who some of you
have heard of I can't like about well
look if you know the the theory that
he's proposing is that if the government
was borrowing so much it would crowd out
money for private investment and
interest rates would go up interest
rates are not going up so that we have
not borrowed enough money where we can
keep borrowing and keep borrowing and
you know this is the type I mean this
type of thing that I mean it sounds like
these guys are mafia loan sharks you
know don't worry though you'll be able
to pay it back you'll be able to pay it
out why don't you take out more money
but here is one the third fact which is
that debt overhang kills growth and it
doesn't necessarily show up in interest
rates this
is the idea of debt overhang comes from
a recent work by the economist Carmen
and Vincent Reinhart and Kenneth Rogoff
and Carmen Reinhart and Kenneth Rogoff
also write an excellent book recently
about financial crises over decade or
over centuries but they defined debt
overhang as moments when the gross
public debt to GDP ratio is greater than
90 percent for at least five years we're
in that according to their understanding
of things debt overhang episodes these
periods of five years or more are
associated with growth over 1% lower
than during other periods so when your
debt to GDP ratio gets above 90% for a
period of time it lowers economic growth
for a long time they looked at 26 cases
going back over the past couple hundred
years the average duration of reduced
growth is about 23 years so that for 23
years
you have average growth that is going to
be 1% or more less than it would have
been absent that much debt and you know
then they also and I'll just summarize
this but that basically what they said
is that this is true even when interest
rates don't spike up which is a kind of
conventional or traditional
understanding of the way that economic
forces would work and what this means
this is a figure a tape or a chart
rather where which shows what what that
really means to say that okay if you
have a debt overhang period this is how
much economic growth suffers as a result
and without the debt overhang is the
blue line up there and you can see just
over a twenty three twenty four year
period a quarter of a century a
generation for God's sake you would
start at a hundred and you would be up
above 220 if you look if you have the
reduced growth rate it's the it's the
red line down there below and you know
think of that slice between those two
lines as all of the jobs that are
missing all of the forward momentum all
of the college all of the education all
of the improvement all of the
unemployment all of the wasted human
capital and lives that's
what's coming because we're in that and
it's not clear exactly how you get out
of that so quickly so now that we've
gone through some bad news I want to
talk about some again surprising facts
one thing that is particularly
interesting is that and I think this is
a minor sign of hope which is that real
per-capita GDP spending by the federal
government has been flat this is a chart
put together by veronique de Russia an
economist at the Mercatus Center is also
a reason columnist and I had actually
asked her a while ago to do this which
what this does is it looks at per capita
using inflation adjusted dollars real
dollars per capita what are the spending
patterns over the past you know 35 40
years and what shows here which is
pretty interesting is that there's a
reliable trend which is that under
Democratic presidents spending tends to
be relatively flat real spending when
you adjust for inflation and population
tends to be flat and the growth periods
come under Republican presidents and
certainly if you look at the bush ii
george w bush that was very much the
case and even when you see obama there's
that big jump up even part of that
spending is due to george bush and the
late late in his final term things like
the tarp bailout and whatnot some of
that was slough tin to 2009 spending
which then got goosed even more by
things like obama's stimulus and whatnot
but this I would argue is a good sign I
mean it's awful that we have this you
know ziggurat of doom going up here but
there's every reason to believe that
Obama or you know the country is not
going to be able to actually increase
spending in the near term very much I
mean we have to fight about we have to
fight on this but people are starting to
understand more and more what's going on
and you know partly because they're
understanding that spending growth is
being driven by and
spending that this is you know which is
something that people don't fully
understand most of the time but this is
a data that was put together by nate
silver of the new york times he runs the
538 blog there and he cuts and slices
data in lots of interesting ways but and
he's a you know a kind of conventional
liberal and you know when he looked at
this this if this is the type of thing
that reason has been reporting for you
know ten years twenty years when
somebody in The New York Times says
isn't its news but what he found was
that you look at annualized growth rates
from 1972 through 2011 and you can see
you know entitlement programs growing by
almost five percent a year
infrastructure and services went up by
about 3% defense 2% interest three point
four percent and boy we're gonna get
slammed when interest rates do go up
they are historically low and that will
not hold forever but total government
spending over that period went up by
three point four percent again driven
mostly by entitlement programs GDP less
than three percent and that's a big part
of our problem is that when you have
spending that's growing faster than the
economy you start getting into a
situation where government spending
keeps growing but the economy doesn't
down what silver said though and what's
interesting and this goes back to an
earlier chart what he noticed though is
that when you think about it in terms of
entitlement spending that's the big
shift and that's the blue part down here
and you can see the blue part is what's
growing up through you know really 1960
entitlement spending wasn't that big a
deal there is basically only Social
Security and some welfare payments by
1970 Medicare and Medicaid had come
fully online and then you know more we I
mean then what's interesting about this
chart is that this doesn't count
Obamacare coming on and it doesn't count
massive increases in Medicare in
particular that are coming very quickly
but basically the role of the federal
government has shifted from being one of
doing infrastructure and services and
to becoming what he said as an insurance
broker and he looked at the fact that
since the early seventies trust and
confidence in government had been going
down at the very same time that
government spending it shifted
dramatically towards entitlement or to
social insurance and he noted in his
piece most of us don't care much for our
insurance broker which I take is a good
sign
because we don't care for our insurance
broker and so we're less likely to do
business with them we don't trust the
government very much this is a Gallup
poll that was taken last fall and the
dark green line are the dark green line
is people who think that the government
most of the time you know can you trust
the government in Washington to do what
is right the dark green line are the
people you know I think they're
colloquially known as suckers they are
people who think the government is
trying to do the best they can or it
does a pretty good job most of the time
it's dropping its down at 19 percent now
whereas the people who are more
skeptical of government power and
government's ability to address all the
ills in the world is rising and that's a
good thing because these are
preconditions to how we get out of the
situation we're in primarily by reducing
the debt to GDP ratio which is a good
thing because people don't only not
trust the government but they don't they
want to reduce the debt this is from the
most recent reason RuPaul and this
should give us cause for optimism it's
not time to celebrate yet because we
haven't made these structural changes
but we're we're getting closer there if
David had said early on you know that
the prerequisite or last night the
prereq prerequisite for change is a felt
need for change now that you know we're
doing a lot of feeling these days
seventy five percent think that the debt
is budget deficits and debts that result
from that is a major problem that the
country must address now that's good
news because that means that there is a
growing recognition that we cannot keep
spending money that we don't have on
projects projects that we don't need and
that is the precondition for political
change and I'm going to end now just
with some quick lines of argument about
ok so if if it's true we need to reduce
the debt to GDP ratio in order to keep
the economy growing faster because this
debt overhang will tamp down growth for
you know it could be a quarter of a
century before we get out of that
situation we have to reduce that to GDP
quickly the best way to do that and this
is also in the Reinhart Reinhart and
Rogoff paper the the best way to do that
is not by raising taxes because that's
one way to minimize deficits but it's to
cut spending they found that in many
cases that that was actually stimulative
of the economy certainly was after World
War 2 where there were major cuts in
government spending in the economy
rather than tanking took off like
nobody's business but how do we what are
the lines of argument for cutting
spending there's a you know here are
some questions that I suggest you ask
friends politicians business leaders
Eskimos whatever Indian chiefs but you
know what do we have to show for a 50%
increase in federal spending since 2001
and by the way 6 to $7 trillion dollars
overall in stimulus when you add up all
the bailouts and when you add up all the
quantitative easing rounds and things
like that
you know we've spent almost half of the
economy of an annual economy to make the
economy grow again and it's not working
it hasn't worked do you want to screw
your kids over that badly because what's
driving debt is Medicare and Social
Security which goes regardless of need
to people who hit a certain number and
that is money that is coming out of your
children's pockets in the form of
payroll taxes and you know you're
they're paying for programs that will
not be there when they retire or if they
are they're starting in 2010 basically
everybody who retires on Social Security
is guaranteed to get less out of the
program than they put in that's a
reversal of the way that the program had
always been so we're basically you know
this is
the question ask your kids what you know
why would you trust anyone over 55
because they're forcing you to pay into
entitlement programs that are not going
to be there for you or treat you worse
than you know the worst kind of
retirement advisor you might have here's
another one because a lot of debt and a
lot of spending is goes to public sector
pensions and public sector compensation
which is at every level it when you
control for the age for the experience
for the education level for the private
sector analogues people in the public
sector are doing better than in the
private sector and you know do you know
that only 15% and that's even a kind of
high estimate work for the public sector
why are we for 15% work for the public
sector I'm sorry is in the yeah that's a
typo thank you very much
or in the public sector we are brokering
or mortgaging our future for 15% of
workers who are making out better than
the rest of us in the private sector it
just doesn't make sense and then finally
to the politicians do you want to get
reelected because this is the changing
point and we saw this with the tea party
you know when they held politicians
accountable for they're bad they're
wicked wicked spending ways and turn
politicians out politicians responded by
actually listening and starting to talk
more there's a reason why we are now
having debates over debt ceiling
increases and why people like Rand Paul
or Mike Lee senator tea party senators
are able to put in budgets or push for
balanced budget amendments and things
like that and it is because politicians
are like you know they're like criminals
in Batman comics there are superstitious
cowardly lot and the minute that they
know that they are going to lose
elections because they are spending too
much money they will find their inner
cheapskate and they'll start coming down
so and with that I'll leave it and we
can take some questions so thank you
all right question would you consider
the post-world War two deficit-reduction
austerity and is that what is required
right now and if so how do you think the
country is going to react and will it be
similar to what's going on with the
protests in parts of Europe like Greece
yeah you know this is also an
interesting debate about austerity
measures and austerity which is you know
best understood as a an attempt to
reduce that's a GDP ratio there are
different ways you can do it you can do
it by cutting spending you can do it by
raising taxes you can do it by a mix of
the two a lot of people have said look
in you know places like Greece and
places like England austerity has been
tried they've cut spending by massive
amounts and it just hasn't work they're
worse off than ever when you look at
virtually any of those actually when you
look at all of those cases the fact of
the matter is that spending has not been
reduced taxes have gone up and they you
know that is austerity is generally i
gets pilloried as cutting Social
Services to the bone and giving tax
breaks to the rich in fact austerity as
it's been practiced in most places is
just hiking taxes and keeping spending
constant are actually increasing and
then when you look at countries that
have recently done differently and this
includes places like Canada in the 90s
Sweden has done this New Zealand has
done this all with in recent memory when
they cut spending and typically they
would cut spending by about four every
dollar in new revenue they might raise
through taxes they cut spending by like
six or more dollars and their economies
right sides very quickly and everybody
was better off the one part that I get
stumped with my progressive friends is
in the discussions of the
unsustainability and for 30 years we've
said that it can't keep going and Paul
Krugman says of course it can keep going
and and so
what answer can I give to my dear
progressive friends that it is gonna end
at some point well yeah this is you know
their I mean the analogy and I think it
came up at dinner as well as that you
know when you jump out of a building
from the hundredth floor everything is
pretty good right up until about the
99th floor and you know just before you
hit the ground that this is where
actually I think the the understanding
of the debt overhang is helpful because
what you know what that formulation
shows is that spending like happen
taking out massive amounts of debt even
if it's low interest so it's like it's a
bargain and things like that it does
have an effect because people know
everybody involved knows deep down that
you're going to have to pay that money
back one way or another and you're
either gonna do it by making that debt
cheaper by hyper and or by inflating or
you're just gonna have to pony up the
money and so the idea of you know what
is unsustainable ultimately is having
unemployment you know creeping around 8%
for year after year after year and it's
it the the you can point to other
countries that did reduce their debt to
GDP ratio overwhelmingly by cutting
spending and that's those economies take
off the ones that don't don't dick
there's a in your prepared remarks you
use the phrase a couple of times we
shouldn't be having spending that we
can't afford something like that and I
would sort of prefer to modify the
message because the spending on the
wrong things whether or not we could
afford it is bad sure and I think on
spending the issue is what they're
spending on because the issue of can we
afford it is far too squirrelly and an
argument can always be made we can
afford it just raise taxes or borrow so
if you ki if you say spending is okay if
we can afford it I don't agree with that
and just I think that's a bad part of
the mantra'
and the second comment is the the trying
to persuade elected officials that
spending money on public employees we
don't get a lot of value is sort of it's
a silly argument in the sense that they
would acknowledge they being the
spenders that is not a question of value
it's vote-buying
spending money on teachers is simply
vote buying and nobody pretends that
it's buying something of value its
buying reelection well you know two
things and thank you for the earlier
point that you're right that just
because you can afford something doesn't
mean that you should go out and purchase
it and you know one of the ways to talk
about this type of stuff is when you
start to look and you know this is other
work that I've done recently one of the
you know the main drivers of runaway
government spending I mean there there
are numerous ones but major ones include
things like defense spending defense
spending is up about seventy percent
from where it was in 2001 and you can
argue ok after 9/11 everything changed
but then at some point did it change
where we're spending seventy percent
more in real dollars and are the threats
worse to us now than they were say in
2001 it's hard to justify any of that
but the other the main drivers are
things like Medicare which is health
care for elderly people are people over
65 Social Security also which is in a in
a bad financial situation and the fact
of the matter is is that most seniors
are in much much better condition
financially than virtually any other
aspect of the population and so to
blindly say that because you're 65 you
deserve Medicare without any you know
without any question about that is wrong
and certainly the financing mechanism is
horrible where it's it's unfair so I do
think you're ripe up to always be
pushing that way to talk about
you know buying votes and whatnot this
is the thing you know again you know
public employees do not rule the world
I mean sometimes it feels that way most
politicians think that but the fact is
is that there are more people who are on
the short end of this stick and that
that that actually can change if we
start pushing this and again one of the
things how many I'm sure a lot of you
were taught growing up you know well if
you have to get a civil service job
because the pay is no good but you have
decent job security and you get good
benefits what has happened over the past
few years as you know finances have
gotten tough and more data has been kind
of dug through and everything's that
people now realize that that's wrong
because actually you have great job
security you have a absolute Cadillac
plan for benefits for health care and
retirement and you get paid more than
your private sector analog and that's
pissing people off and that's one of the
reasons why people like scott walker in
wisconsin is able to actually not only
take on public sector compensation but
actually win recall elections so I Nick
I walk back here listen I agree with
everything you said and I agree with all
the data except your first you know your
there's number one problem is spending
and then number four you put up a slide
that you said someone else gave it to
you I think a progressive think tank
gave it to you because it says I mean
spendings up over the last four years we
can bring back the spendings up like 30
percent over the last four years yet
spending per capita you said is flat I
don't think that that can't be possible
why why not write the population had
would have to grow 30 percent in the
last four years it would have to be
completely relative and it's not
population hasn't grown 30 percent in
four years federal outlays per capita in
inflation-adjusted dollars for instance
in the fiscal year 2012 the federal
government actually spent less money
than it did in fiscal year 2011 and this
is the upside of a dysfunctional
government
that can't write a budget essentially
what happened because the government
spending was bit was done through
continuing resolutions there was not an
opportunity to actually jack up spending
so those figures by the way are drawn
from the you know the historical budget
tables of the OMB there's no question
about that and it's interesting and to
you know dig deep into that because if
you are Pro Republican you know the
Republicans have a lot of explaining to
do and it's interesting progressives who
think that the Democrats are great
because they give away the bank you know
Democrats also have something to explain
but this is largely a function of the
fact that Obama got a big increase
coming in and then since then they
haven't you know there hasn't been a
federal budget in you know coming up on
four years and that meant that it's
actually very difficult to spend more
money in your great book wide
libertarian politics can solve the
problems I believe something along those
lines available at amazon.com you talked
about you and Matt talked about the
government being out of money yes you
wrote this in 2010 and here we are in
January February of 2013 and the
government continues on all levels to be
able to finance itself right state local
and federal help by a trillion dollars a
year of federal are of fed money
printing have you thought through the
endgame of that and what point do you
think the one or more levels of
government will no longer be able to
finance themselves yeah it's you know
it's an interesting question and I think
Matt would agree with me on this one
thing we didn't anticipate we thought
when we went out and talked about things
that people would be like yeah you're
right we are out of money you know we
got to change now and it it turned out
that that message had not really sunk
through or people understand it but I
don't
how many of you have either been
bankrupt or extremely poor at various
points where you know it takes you a
while to realize like when you're out of
money that you can't keep doing
everything that you've been doing and
that I think we're still in this phase
where we're still fully kind of grokking
the idea that we are broke and we have
to change our spending almost
immediately I do think that you're
starting to see you know the Canaries in
the coal mine are cities that are going
bankrupt that Julian and Adrian talked a
bit about places like Harrisburg the
credit ratings on a bunch of states as
well as on the federal government you
know on the federal government have gone
down so the the the early signs are
there but you know at a certain point
this is one of the problems with with
credit crunches and with bankruptcies
and things like that everything is okay
until suddenly it isn't and you know
this as much as anything is you know
these are Cassandra calls to stop before
it's really totally irredeemable Nick
what were you up to when you were four
years old and what has happened since
then
am I allowed to curse use profanity and
the item Jerry you're gonna have to give
me a little more to work with on that
you